- [Announcer] This program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(rhythmic, alerting music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Dr. Lucy Jones,
who is the fall 2015 Hitchcock Lecturer.
She is a distinguished seismologist
and education advocate.
She has been a seismologist
with the US Geological Survey
and a visiting research associate
at the Seismological Laboratory
of Cal Tech since 1983.
Dr. Jones, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thanks for having me.
- [Harry] Where were you born and raised?
- I am a native Southern Californian.
I was born in Santa Monica and spent
almost all of my childhood
somewhere in Southern California.
- Looking back, how do
you think your parents
influenced your thinking about the world?
- Oh, extremely fundamentally.
My father was a aerospace engineer
and loved science, loved
math, just all of that
and taught me the joy of math
at a time when girls were often
not encouraged to be doing it,
and, he would sometimes, it was like,
"Yeah, women don't do math,
but you're my daughter.
"Of course you do it."
And then my mother was
actually a spiritual director,
someone who did counseling
and advice to people.
So I sort of saw both the
value of logical reasoning
and then the emotional side of
how people respond to things.
- So both sides of the brain
were activated. (laughs)
- I really see the
influence of both of them
in the way my career has
ended up playing out.
- What was it like growing
up in earthquake country?
Did that affect you at all?
- Not really, because it was
a very quite time relatively speaking.
My first memory is an earthquake.
I think I was two years old.
I've actually tried to
reconstruct where it was, and,
my mom, gathering up us children,
getting us in the hall, dropping down.
She covered us with her body.
So I have that distinct memory.
The biggest earthquake we
had in Southern California
was the '71 San Fernando
earthquake and I wasn't there.
I was actually living with
my aunt and uncle in Taiwan.
So I got a early lesson
in communication issues
where the news in Taiwan was
Los Angeles destroyed by earthquake.
(Harry laughs)
So, I try to call my parents,
and I can't get through.
The phone lines are all
jammed and they don't call me.
And I was just terrified
that something really wrong had happened.
They had no damage at all.
They were waiting for my birthday,
which was four days later,
to call me to wish me happy birthday.
So, found early on, the difference between
how it's portrayed and
what the reality is.
- But, before you went to college,
what was it like being a
girl and then a young woman,
and wanting to do science?
Were you discouraged?
- Well, yeah, the schools
tried to discourage me.
That's why I think my
father was so important.
I had a counselor that, when
I scored a perfect score
on the science aptitude
test, accused me of cheating
and made me retake it in front of her.
I had (laughs), I had a math teacher that,
when I got into both Brown and Harvard,
tried to convince me that
I should go to Harvard
because there was a better
class of men to marry there.
I went to Brown.
So, yeah, the attitude
about women and science,
when I was in high
school, was just assuming
you couldn't possibly get there.
By the time I got to
college, it was the start,
I started in the fall of '72,
the beginning of the women's movement,
so people were no longer
saying those things,
but the girls had been
discouraged earlier.
So I was always the only girl in my class.
Then when I got to MIT,
I was the only woman
going into geophysics that year.
By two years later, the incoming
class was a third women.
So I was sort of right at the cusp,
just before women stopped hearing
the sort of things I heard in high school.
- What did you major in at Brown?
- I began as a physics major,
but one of the nice things about Brown is
there's no distribution requirement,
so you can go in depth at other things.
So I was taking Chinese as my language.
I had lived in Taiwan in high school.
My grandparents had been
missionaries in China.
Half the family spoke Chinese.
So I started studying Chinese.
And you either have to get,
you either drop out or get obsessed.
You can't do it halfway.
And, I got obsessed.
I spent my junior year of college
back in Taipei studying Chinese.
Took my first geology class
as a senior and fell in love.
Read the 900-page
textbook in the first week
'cause I couldn't put it down.
- (laughs) And it was
in English, I assume.
- It was in English.
Actually I had tried
to do science in Taiwan
'cause I knew I was
going to be a scientist.
And I discovered that the lessons were,
all of the technical words
were given in English anyway.
(speaks in foreign language) equation.
So I gave up doing that.
When I switched from
physics to geophysics,
I actually took the Chinese degree,
'cause, after my year in Taiwan,
I had all the requirements,
and that left me free to take geophysics
and structural geology instead
of advanced electromagnetics.
- And why the move from
physics to geophysics,
or any reason in particular?
- Oh, yeah.
I wasn't sure what I wanted to do.
I don't think a lot of college
people, I've, you know,
Maybe I wanted to go
in the Foreign Service.
Maybe I wanted to be a scientist.
Maybe I wanted to be a musician.
So I was still exploring and I
met a couple of geophysicists
at a breakfast in my dorm.
Talked with them for a few hours
and they got me interested
enough to take the geology class.
Once I took it, I realized,
this is what I was looking for.
It was a way of using
that scientific analysis
for things that mattered more.
Instead of building bombs,
I could be predicting earthquakes.
At least back in the '70s,
we still thought we'd be doing that.
- Then you went to MIT for your PhD
and what did you do your dissertation on?
- I did my dissertation
on earthquakes in China.
So, when I went to apply
to graduate school,
fluent in Chinese,
In 1975 there had been
an earthquake in China
with over 500 foreshocks
and, as far as we could tell,
this was the Cultural Revolution time,
it had been predicted.
It looked like there were
a lot of lives saved.
So when I applied to
MIT and I spoke Chinese,
they said, "Why don't we
get you studying foreshocks
"and then, if China ever
opens up, we can send you over
"and you can try and
understand what happened here."
It worked with perfect timing.
I had just passed my generals exams
when the president's science
advisor, Frank Press,
went to China and they
wanted an exchange program.
Here's 60 Chinese ready to go.
So the Americans were scrambling
to try and do it really quickly,
and I was able to put in this application.
I had just written this
paper on foreshocks.
I'm fluent in Chinese.
The Chinese looked to
be the farthest along
on earthquake prediction.
Put it all together, and it worked.
And it didn't hurt that the
president's science advisor
was actually my recommendation
because he had been the
chair of the department
when I had started at MIT.
So, I got to be in that first group.
There were six scientists
and then seven students
who went to (speaks in foreign language),
to Peking University.
But I was actually, I went
over with the students.
I was actually the first scientist
because I was the only
one who wasn't a professor
and, therefore, could leave
in the middle of the term.
The rest of them had to wait
'til they finished the teaching
and they came in May and June.
- What was that like?
You were talking about a time when
China has not taken off economically yet.
- And it was still a very,
much more restrictive society.
When I arrived there,
everybody was in Mao suits.
By the end of the first year,
some women might be using colored scarves
and that was, like, radical.
I was the 35th American
to arrive in Beijing.
It was a time, they had
just started allowing,
A Chinese woman could be
alone in a room with me,
but a Chinese man couldn't.
When I went to the
Institute of Geophysics,
interestingly, Chinese
didn't have the thing
about women not doing math,
so there were plenty of women.
One of the women scientists
was assigned to work with me.
It took a while for me to figure out
that somebody would come in
and she was off in the
bathroom or something,
and he'd see me there and
turn around and leave,
come back later when she was there,
and then want to talk to me, not her.
It was a subtle enough thing, I'm like
trying to finally figure this out.
Then when I went to the
Institute of Geology,
there were no women, 'cause
women didn't do fieldwork.
That was sort of the prejudice there.
There were two geologists
assigned to work with me
and, if one of them went to the bathroom,
the other one got up and walked out too.
So it was still a very,
much more politically-restrictive time.
All my mail was read.
But it was also a very egalitarian time.
Nobody was rich, but
nobody was really poor.
In Taiwan you would see beggars.
There were no beggars in China.
My aunt came to visit me
and she had been born
and brought up in China.
She was so astonished
to see trees because,
when she was in Nantsing in the '30s,
the trees would always get
cut down for wood by somebody
that would steal the trees
because they were so poor
they couldn't afford the fuel.
That people were well-enough
off to let the trees grow,
to her, was astonishing.
Of course, now, China's
growing economically.
It's a very different place,
but it's also a much less
egalitarian place than it was.
- You must have gone back
several times as a scientist.
- I actually--
- What are your impressions
of how it has changed on the human level?
- I haven't gone back since 1983.
- [Harry] Oh, okay.
- So I went four times and
the last time I was there,
we uncovered a case of scientific fraud.
It wasn't like it was widespread fraud.
It was an individual.
But, it was reflective
of the system at the time
that it hadn't been caught.
And, partly, the core of
the scientific process,
is that we attack each other.
I think it's one of the reasons
you don't see as many women researchers.
We finally go, hey, I
don't like the environment.
But, a core of being a scientist is
tearing apart your colleagues.
That's how we find the truth.
You don't have to be mean.
Sometimes people are, but,
you need to be critical.
As we were discovering
the problem in China
and trying to explain
it, and we're saying,
you know somebody's gonna review this
and they're gonna ask
why this looks wrong,
or, looks different from
something in the past,
and they were like, well we
just say this is what we did.
No, they're gonna want to understand why.
He's like, "Why would
they think we're lying?"
It was sort of this light for me that,
at that time, the culture of China
where (speaks in foreign language),
the spirit of the guest, politeness,
is necessary to function in a
society that is that crowded.
So there's a very strong cultural aversion
to what's necessary in science,
of sort of the attack on each other.
And, at the time, we saw
it as sort of symptomatic,
and I thought, I really
need to establish my career
somewhere other than
China 'cause, at the time,
I was the woman who went to China.
Of course it's changed radically
now, the whole interchange.
That part is really not
the issue that it was.
But once I got really
established in California
and then my children were born,
I've ended up never going back.
- I like to ask my guests
about what they see
as the skills and temperament
to do the work they do.
First let me ask you about
being a seismologist.
You've already identified some just now,
but tell us a little more.
What is the skillset you really need
and what is the temperament
that is desirable?
- Wow.
A fundamental, I think,
of most scientists,
number one, is being an introvert,
that thinking six months alone
in front of a computer terminal
is a good way to spend your life.
And that's a pretty core
difference with a lot of the world.
Because you need to have that ability
to focus and tune out the other parts.
A scientific advance happens because you,
you've been able to get
down and isolate one factor
off from everything else.
So you do all your work down in the weeds.
You need to be able to part
out each piece of the weed
and go, if I change only this one piece,
this is how the result changes.
And then you've proven what's
the control factor there.
Especially in seismology.
Earthquakes are such a complex process,
it's very difficult to get into the weeds.
There's so many weeds there.
You've gotta have that
ability to dig down.
You need to have that ability to,
God, how do you,
to part the pieces, to
see where they line up.
I actually think that one
of the really key issues
is how to ask the right question.
My dad used to like to say this.
There's the set of all of the
questions that we can answer
and there's the set of the questions
that people want answers to.
Finding where that intersection is
is where productive stuff happens.
It isn't necessarily a
general characteristic
among all scientists, but,
it's a really important
one to be able to have.
- What about temperament?
You've already talked a little about that.
I mean, you've gotta be argumentative
and stand your ground, obviously.
- Yes, you need to have
enough confidence to do this.
There was a point in my graduate career
with my thesis advisor,
who was a brilliant man,
and dedicated, and very critical.
I then was also doing some
lab work with someone else,
who was more complimentary.
I finally went to my
first adviser and said,
I think it's clear you
don't like what I'm doing.
Professor Brace does.
Why don't I move over?
And he looked at me, he goes,
"What are you talking about?
"You're the best student I have," which,
I started crying which was like, oh great,
just what they need to have from a woman.
We ended up having this long talk
and he really didn't realize,
because that's part of what you do,
you direct a person by (mumbles) them,
and so you have to have that confidence
to believe that you're right.
It does require a level of
arrogance to fight for yourself.
And yet, if you are too arrogant,
you don't hear what the others are doing.
Another core piece of science is that you,
We are wrong most of the time.
You spend your time
researching things and,
this is a dead end and this is a dead end,
and you've proven that this doesn't work.
It's in pursuit of a bigger right, right?
And we like being right.
Human beings love being right.
But you have to be relatively
comfortable with being wrong
and that, also recognizing
that every advance
is disproving something else.
So you have to be
comfortable with uncertainty.
You have to accept, I
believe this is right,
but if some other piece
of information comes along
that proves it wrong, I need
to be willing to let go of it.
And, at least with scientists,
we believe that data conquers all.
There was a famous story
from early plate tectonics
that my professor told me of
one particular track of
data that's really proved
the seafloor-spreading ideas.
The famous guy who had
been opposed to the idea,
the data's presented,
everybody's quiet as he exams it.
It was a famous meeting in 1968.
And he finally just looked at
the other authors and went,
"Congratulations," and
walked outta the room.
It was like so humiliating
he couldn't stay
and talk with them, but he
could say congratulations.
And that's sort of the ideal of science
is that you can give it up.
- Throughout your career,
we talked about the earlier stages,
how did the glass ceiling
for women come down?
Or was this not a problem as
you did so well in your field?
- It's a mixed bag.
I'm late enough that it wasn't,
nobody would be explicitly
saying, women can't do it.
10 years earlier, you get told
you don't get the place in the class.
It goes to a man who's not
gonna get married and leave.
We didn't get that, but, there
is a certain amount that,
I don't have the highest
level of recognition
in the USGS for my work.
It hasn't really gotten
in the way, though,
and I think that going to work
for the US Geological Survey
instead of an academic institution,
relieves some of the problems.
There is a bit more of a structure.
There's a little more objectivity
to how the promotion process happens.
And, I don't need to have
the big academic recognition
to have the freedom to go and do my work.
I actually think that in, sort of,
not in the research itself,
I mean the research sort of,
gender is somewhat less obvious.
I did, at what point, decide I should
use initials instead of my name on papers,
so it wasn't obvious that I was a woman.
But my last name is Jones.
(Harry laughs)
And then I started getting confused
with a whole lot of other people,
so I decided I'd better not do that.
But, in the role that I ended up taking on
of how to communicate about
the science to the public,
that's where my gender started
becoming a very positive thing.
There was a rather famous
incident with a big earthquake
20 years ago, where my husband,
who's also a seismologist,
literally, handed me our baby
in the middle of an interview.
And I ended up doing
interviews carrying a baby.
It caused a huge public
outpouring of support
because, actually, when
you think about it,
why do you want to
talk to a seismologist
after an earthquake anyway?
Knowing what fault it's on
is not gonna help you rebuild your house.
But knowing what fault
it's on and hear me say,
give it a number, give it
a name, give it a fault,
I'm saying, somebody
understands what happened to you
and that makes it less scary.
And then you do it with
the image of motherhood.
You always feel better when
mommy tells you it's okay
than when daddy does.
So, it actually, I think,
encouraged people's response to me
and allowed me to be a
more effective communicator
because of the, sort of,
emotional connection that people formed.
- What is your most important
research accomplishment in seismology?
It's dealing with--
- [Lucy] I gotta pick one? (laughs)
- Yeah, yeah. (laughs)
- Okay. Let me give you two.
- Okay.
- The early stage of my
career came out of China
and was doing probabilities
of earthquake sequences.
So, there's this earthquake in China.
They did evacuate places
because there was this big
swarm of earthquakes going on.
What I came to realize
is, they didn't know more
about those earthquakes than we do.
The fact that they happened,
increased the probability
of an earthquake,
but it still wasn't a 50% probability.
And, in fact, they evacuated other times,
oop, no earthquake, go back in.
And in China, you could do that,
and still get people to
go out the next time.
For us, not because of
scientific differences,
but because of social differences,
we couldn't respond to the same
information in the same way.
Realizing that wasn't
a scientific question.
So I said, how do I get
that scientific information
to the policymaker who really
should be making the decision?
And therefore got into statistics,
ended up being the one who
created the first assessment of
what's the chance that one
earthquake will be a foreshock.
It has been the basis of all
of the earthquake advisories
in the State of California so,
when we have something
near the San Andreas,
and we make a statement
about the probability
of the San Andreas earthquake,
that's all based on
research that I was part of.
Or that an earthquake happens,
what's your chance of aftershocks?
What pattern are they gonna be taking?
- And what was the key there?
What did you determine allows
you to make the prediction?
- Well, it was actually just
recognizing that we could,
It wasn't that difficult.
It was dividing one number into another.
It was saying, let's
just go use the history.
And when I go and look at the
history, 5% of earthquakes
were followed by something
bigger within three days.
It didn't seem to be
dependent on the magnitude
of the first earthquake.
So, that became a relative
quite simple statement
that we could make and move forward.
Also showing that the temporal decay
of main shocks after foreshocks,
is the same as aftershocks
after main shocks.
So you could end up saying that
a foreshock is just a main shock
that happens to have a
really big aftershock
and that you can mathematically express
the full range of earthquake triggering
with the same set of equations.
So it became a unified approach
to being able to do that
and then, as we've gone
into computer eras,
you can then do automatic processing
and immediately say,
these type of numbers.
So, it was both the scientific analysis
that allowed us to come
up with those numbers,
but it pushed me even
more into the social side
because I'm now working
with emergency managers
and they're misunderstanding
the information.
We say there's a 5%
chance of an earthquake
within the next three days and,
instead of within three days,
it becomes in three days,
and they're doing things now
for the earthquake coming in three days
and I'm going, no, no, no, wait a minute.
Right now is the most dangerous time.
And it sort of gave me
very concrete examples
of how the communication barrier
was affecting the way in which
the information could get used.
- You said two of many achievements.
What was the second one?
- Okay, well then the second one would be
what's happened in the last decade.
So, with the social
interaction, starting to say,
we need to do a better job
of getting our science used.
I was given the opportunity to lead
what was called the Multi-Hazards
Demonstration Project
to demonstrate how hazard science
could improve a community's
resilience to natural disasters.
I actually thought, in accepting that,
that I was, basically, walking
away from my academic career.
I said to myself, all right, I'm 50.
Maybe I have another 30 papers to write,
and five of them will be read
and two of them will matter.
But if I don't do it, I
can see the young people
who are gonna write those two papers,
whereas if I don't do the
Multi-Hazards Project,
it wouldn't get done, so, okay.
I'll sacrifice my academic
career, go and do this.
We'll see what the
community wants from us.
And, we asked the emergency
managers, land-use planners,
what do you need from
science you're not getting?
Got a very strong message
that they wanted scenarios,
and my first thought was, oh damn,
why did I say I'd do what they wanted?
That sounds really boring.
Okay, it's what you want.
Now how do we do it right?
And ended up being able
to bring together teams.
Literally, we had over 300 people
working on our first big scenario,
which was of a San Andreas earthquake
in Southern California.
Making sure we did cutting-edge science,
we did the best we could
in dozens of disciplines.
Instead of saying, okay, I'm an engineer,
I've got the best possible engineering
and I'll just grab something
from the seismologist
and grab something from the economist,
make sure we got the best seismologist,
the best engineer, the best economist.
The result was a much
more concrete picture
of what, the result, what it means
when we give you a
probability of an earthquake.
We needed the best science
so we had the credibility.
But we needed to do
this integrated approach
so that people understood it
and saw how it related to their lives.
I ended up publishing
40 papers in 10 years.
So I turned out not to be
cutting off my academic career
and has really led to a lot of
the recognition I've had recently
because it's about getting science used.
- It sounds to me like
something in your background
gave you
the capacity to have
your ear to the ground
and not just to listen to earthquakes.
In other words, to be
sensitive, on the one hand,
to the implications of science
and what you can do with science,
but then, understand the
difficulty of doing that.
Where did that come from, that skillset?
- Well, okay.
I think it's a range of things.
Both my parents played a role.
My mom as being a spiritual director,
cared about how people were feeling.
That was honored and important
and an awareness around me.
I tended to be more like my father
and she would be terribly
frustrated with me
as I was way to analytical for her.
But even my father, he prided
himself on being able to
find that intersection of
the questions we could answer
and the questions that
people needed the answer to.
And so, not just the science,
but how it gets used.
And then, the experience in China
was a really big piece of doing that.
By seeing that, how the science was used
was completely different,
not because of the science
but because of the social settings.
And that, they should
evacuate because they had ton,
hundreds of thousands of people
dying in their buildings.
We could kill more people on the freeway
than we save by the prediction.
So that process.
And then, it evolves with the being on TV,
getting this response to my being on TV.
And part of that led to me
being named to the
Seismic Safety Commission,
which is a state political body.
And I was the only seismologist.
You have emergency managers,
utilities, local government,
all the stakeholders in
the earthquake problem.
And that's where I was
overwhelmed at seeing
how much really basic
stuff about earthquakes
that is so basic, the scientists
don't bother to talk about it, because
we should be teaching it in 8th grade.
But we don't teach
earthquakes in 8th grade.
Somehow California
doesn't think its citizens
need to know anything about
earthquakes to live here
and so we're seeing decision makers
not using really basic information.
And that was the big lesson
I took out of the Seismic
Safety Commission.
That we need to step back
and communicate the stuff
that no longer interests us as scientists,
but is needed by the population to use it.
- So, in a way, you're suggesting
that science education,
if it exists, is really about
training people to be scientists.
And you're worrying about
the people who need science
in whatever they're gonna do.
- Right, I mean this is, to me,
I think it's a fundamental flaw in society
that is being exacerbated
in the internet age.
So, we, generally, treat science education
as the process of filtering
through all the people
and finding out who can become scientists.
And even when you hear people
talking about the need for STEM education,
it's because we have
all these STEM careers.
It's not because non-scientists
need to think this way.
And yet, we've reached,
I actually like to compare it
to what we used to treat reading,
as something that only
the specialists needed.
Then you have the Industrial Age
and you have the printing press,
and, instead of getting your information
from the priest talking
to you from the pulpit,
you're supposed to be reading
yourself in the newspaper.
And you could still support
yourself with that reading,
but you couldn't be part
of the social discourse.
Now we have the switch
into the internet era
in which we no longer
have the restrictions of
the cost of publishing restricting
the information you get.
We used to have editors that said
this is worth publishing and this isn't.
Now, everything's out there
and you're now supposed to be
making that decision yourself,
whether this is information
worth listening to.
That is science research skill.
The skill of science is how to
analyze the significance of data
and determine what part's worth
listening to and what isn't.
How do you know for
yourself something's true?
A scientist doesn't believe something
because 97% of other
scientists believe it.
We're affected by that.
We assume that we can do our own analysis
and figure out whether
or not it's believable.
I believe in climate change
because it's really basic facts.
I can go into a chemistry
lab and watch what happens
when I have more carbon dioxide in a gas
and I trap more heat.
And I can measure the carbon
dioxide and there's more there.
It's basic.
I do the analysis myself
and, we are not training
non-scientists to think that way.
I think that is a huge flaw in our society
that's leading to really
bad decision making because,
And, we've actually got sort
of a cultural thing right now
where things don't have to be true.
We can make them true
because we believe them.
We're just gonna say it's true
until everybody else agrees.
That works for human motivation.
It doesn't work for physical fact.
And we have a really scary
thing going on in society
that, it's sort of the journalist idea.
There's no truth.
There's always another side of the story.
Well, to a scientist, there's truth.
You just have a better or
worse representation of it.
- So what would a curriculum look like
that taught scientific skills,
but not just for the scientist?
Do you mix the students up, that is,
the ones who wanna be scientists?
Or, do you have special courses?
- I think that, well, I think
that we need to be doing this
in elementary and secondary education.
So, this is before you've separated out.
What I've heard of the
next-generation science standards,
there's a lot of the
right things in there,
that, instead of saying the
student needs to understand
what the parts of the periodic table are,
the student needs to
understand how to make a model.
The student needs to be able to model
the nature of chemical interaction.
I've seen some high school chemistry stuff
where you say, okay, why do
x-rays pass through your body
but not through the lead apron?
You come up with a hypothesis and then,
you do the lecture series
on reaction energies
and you discover it isn't
'cause it's extra dense,
it's because it takes,
it absorbs the x-rays
because the, you can't excite the,
it takes too much energy to excite the
electrons up into the upper orbitals.
Almost nobody knows that, and yet,
so you then modify the hypotheses.
So it's teaching the children
how to make a model and
assess it against data.
In the process you learn these facts
that we also think people need to know,
but you do it through
a framework of saying,
how do I go from a hypothesis
to an assessment of the hypothesis?
- You've been involved in a
lot of public mass teach-ins
I guess you would call them, where people
actually pretend there is
an earthquake or a tsunami.
Talk a little about that,
because that's another form of education
when people actually live through an event
that hasn't happened yet.
- Right, so this was part of
the Multi-Hazards Demonstration Project.
We said, we're demonstrating how it'll
actually improve resilience.
Terrifying thing to a scientist,
to define the success by
something we don't control,
but we are defining it by how
somebody uses our information
instead of the information we create.
So we were looking at this.
How do we get people to understand
what we discovered about the earthquake
in a way that'll change behavior?
So we turned to the social sciences.
Actually, there's a lot
of information there
on how people get information.
We created the first, what was called,
The Great Southern California Shakeout
as a method of getting
people to understand
what was in our scenario
of a San Andreas earthquake
which was also called
the Shakeout Scenario.
One of the big ones we heard is that
people do what they
see other people doing.
Visual reinforcement really
affects people's behavior.
It's why fashion works.
We see other people wearing things.
So we needed to find a way of
seeing other people
preparing for an earthquake.
So we focused on the Drop,
Cover, Hold On drill.
It's a good thing to do.
Plenty of Californians didn't
got to Californian schools,
so they never learned it.
And it's a very strong visual.
Sitting under a table,
you look sort of idiotic,
but it's very clearly getting
ready for the earthquake.
So it was that visual reinforcement.
They also tell us people do what,
They need to talk with
others they care about
about what happens to make
the decision to do it.
So we had the drill in a way that
schools and businesses,
we tried to encourage them
to do the drill on the same day.
So you'd come home from work and,
mommy, I had a earthquake drill today.
Oh, I had one too.
You start talking about it at home.
So we worked with the social scientist
and tried to create it.
We intended it as a one-time event.
We ended up getting 5 1/2
million people in the first event
which is 1/4 of the population
of Southern California.
You get 1/4, five million
people to do the same thing,
elected officials take notice,
and the State of California
came to us and said,
we wanna make this an annual event.
My first thought was, oh,
no, I've already given you a year, enough!
It's been really interesting
watching how it's developed.
We had over 26 million
people last year, in 2014,
in the Shakeout, somewhere
across the country.
We've seen it spread to a lot of regions.
We've seen it a bit
disconnected from the science,
and that part, to me, I'd like to try and
get people to reconnect.
So we did it, first time, off of
the particular science scenario.
And in Southern California, it's still
very much tied to that scenario.
As it spread elsewhere, they
don't have their own local ones
and I'd like to see more people, really,
try to develop those
comprehensive scenarios
so when people are doing
the drill, it's connected to
what the science tells them
is really gonna happen.
- You feel that there is
a communication problem
between what scientists know
and, beyond these drills,
getting people to
understand the implications
of what might be a
catastrophe or a disaster.
Talk a little about that
because I think you're saying
that we need better narratives,
better storytelling,
to get people to have a
handle on what's happening.
- Well
- or what might happen.
- What will happen.
And I think that that's it.
We actually understand a lot
about what was happening.
And many people, especially
with earthquakes,
it's true to a,
In a lot of the disasters,
they think it's capricious.
This building was
damaged, this one wasn't.
Who knows what's gonna happen?
Well, in fact, this one's on softer soil.
This one had retrofitted its foundation.
It's a very complex pattern.
But we, in fact, really
understand very well,
which buildings and where
the damage is gonna be.
So it was, how do we get
people to believe this?
One of the things that's been in the way
is the siloing of science.
You have the seismologist that tells you
where the shaking's gonna be.
You have an engineer that tells you
how your building responds.
We have an economist looking
at social interactions.
We have an infrastructure.
And the pieces are hard to connect up,
and especially on an earthquake
that doesn't happen that often.
What we did in creating our
scenarios was to create a story.
And, even more, a
scientifically defensible story.
So, when you look at how
people make decisions,
they do it because of stories
and because of their
emotional connection to it.
Scientists hate stories.
We are trained in graduate
school to believe,
and it's true, stories are misleading.
Stories tell you as an anecdote.
The whole point of science
is to not be mislead
by anecdotes and make sure
that it happens every time.
So, we're trained, early on,
to reject stories and never use them.
And yet, that is how most
of the rest of the world
communicates and makes decisions.
So what we did in the scenario process was
try to bridge that gap.
It's only as I look back that I realize
that that, what was
important about the process,
so that, when you have the,
And the hardest part was actually
getting the scientists
to agree to the story.
Because, in doing a
scenario of an earthquake,
I have to make a lot of assumptions.
I assume exactly and,
I've made so many assumptions,
the next earthquake will not be that one.
Some of the details will be different.
And that's where we live, is
in the details, as scientists.
We had a really difficult time
with the scientists going,
you can't be sure that's what it is.
And we're going, we don't need to be sure.
We need to say it's plausible.
That became the most
important word we could use.
Plausible became the bridge
between the scientists
living in our uncertainty
and knowing all those possibilities,
to the people who needed
a concrete narrative
to be able to act on it.
And plausible became our bridge.
- So let's develop this
a little further, so,
if you were working up a scenario
and you said, well, an earthquake will hit
this block or this area
of houses in Oakland
sometime in the future.
Then, is the point to say,
well, if there is
structural damage to houses,
then the following happens?
People aren't gonna have a place to live.
People may abandon their property.
Are those the kind of--
- That's the kind of things
but it's actually a pretty
long narrative going,
okay, here's the fault.
The Hayward Fault is very capable of it.
What would the pattern of damage,
What is the pattern of shaking gonna be?
Because that's what seismology does.
Many people think that an
earthquake happens at a point.
It's at the epicenter, right?
No, it's over a surface.
So, what is that distribution of shaking,
and how we're gonna,
We know bad soils give you worse shaking.
But, we have to model
exactly what the slip is
and it's gonna be some different pattern.
All right, so but we pick
one of those patterns.
This is plausible.
Now we've got these neighborhoods
that have this impact
and this damage to this buildings
and this damage to this infrastructure,
and that means we've now got,
a population of renters
who've lost their housing
and they've also lost their
job because there's no water
and, therefore, that
restaurant had to shut down.
Okay, I'm gonna give up
and go stay with my family
down in Southern California.
I'm going out to Pacoima.
We start losing population.
And how to make the connections
between all of those
things in a plausible way.
The reality is, it's
a very complex system.
The final one will be different.
But this is the type of information.
And then we go back and go and say,
we'll lookit, that really key issue
became the loss of water.
If we could get our water pipes fixed
so that we kept those jobs,
people would be willing to do it.
We end up saying, usually
there's three or four or five things
that seem to be the biggest problems.
And then we can take it to
elected officials to let,
urban planners and go,
if you don't fix this,
you have the potential
of losing your society.
And then we go and look at places
like New Orleans after Katrina.
Show them what happened
to the GDP of New Orleans.
It's a very compelling argument.
- You were an advisor to
the mayor of Los Angeles
and the goal, what you decided was
to identify certain vulnerabilities
and show them in scenarios
like you just did.
- Well, yes, it was an
interesting process.
So we had already done
the Shakeout Scenario.
We had some really clear things
that were really big problems.
We had a new mayor, very
energetic, intelligent man
who wanted to address
some of the big issues.
I actually negotiated this
out with the deputy mayor.
It's a very interesting process.
We couldn't go in and say,
we're gonna solve the earthquake problem.
That's defining the problem to fail
because the problem is so big,
there's no way we can deal
with it all in a year.
So let's define areas that
are really critical needs
and that we know we have
a path to a successful,
We have something we could do
that would make a difference.
So we only chose areas that we knew we had
something to do that would be
able to look like a success.
That was the political necessity.
But then we had the freedom to
explore the range of problems.
So what we ended up
recommending out of the process
had some of those easy
fixes that, well not easy,
but easily-defined fixes,
that we knew would be needed,
but then, in many cases,
we were able to go
quite a bit beyond it.
But we didn't try to go out
and solve other problems
because you concentrate your effort
where it's gonna make
the biggest difference.
That's a hard thing for a scientist to,
sort of, political necessity
and the pragmatism of it.
We're much more inclined to say,
here's the range of problems,
and narrowing down and
doing concrete actions.
- You've worked at various
levels of government.
And, in all state and the city,
and one thing that strikes me
that is common to all these levels
is they don't have a long-term perspective
because of the next election.
And so that's a problem
you have to deal with
'cause you're talking
about fixing the pipes
that bring the water
and the pipes are wooden
and they cross the San Andreas Fault.
So sometime in the future,
- Right.
- and it's not gonna work.
- Well, it's an interesting thing.
There was a really
interesting editorial in a
downtown LA newspaper after
Mayor Garcetti announced
the Resilience by Design Program.
And they were saying, politicians always
walk away from the earthquake problem
because, if you go and decide
you wanna spend money on it,
either there won't be an earthquake
before you're out of office,
and then why did you waste our money?
Or, there will be an earthquake
before you're out of office
and your changes won't have
had time to take effect,
so, you look ineffective.
So, mostly it gets ignored.
And then they proceeded to
go and give Mayor Garcetti
huge political credit for
having worked on something
for which he didn't get political credit.
So it's been sort of
an interesting dynamic.
I think that I was accepted in,
really because of an individual's insight.
I credit Mayor Garcetti a lot
for the courage to take this on
and to just say, I care about Los Angeles,
and I don't care if it's not
gonna happen before I'm done.
I'm gonna work on this.
So, it took political courage
and it took the vision to
see what the issues were.
What's very very encouraging,
is watching how much status and credit
he's getting for having done it.
So we're now seeing
other political leaders
wanting to start tackling
with the issues as well.
There are numerous cities in Southern,
in Los Angeles County, that
are looking now to adopt
the same regulations that Los
Angeles has just put in place.
So, yes, it tends to be a problem.
The political world forces you
to look at a pretty short timeframe.
But, the best elected officials
realize that the future of
their city is bigger than that
and to do the planning that
carries the city forward.
You need to have that to get this to work.
- It'd be interesting to identify
some of the elements here
that you have learned in this process
of awakening people to the
long-term problems of earthquakes
because, obviously, the
insights you've gathered
apply to things like climate change.
The first thing that comes to mind
in the case of climate change,
less so in the case of earthquakes,
is the politicization of the process,
which is to say, the science
is bad or, it's inaccurate
and this group or that group
will fund disinformation.
So it's not just that people don't know,
but there is disinformation
being produced.
- I see a couple of issues tied into this.
One is that, people don't feel empowered
to make the decision for themselves.
They believe in something because
they believe the person who's saying it
rather than their own
ability to analyze it.
But I also see a lot of
science communication issues
that feed into this.
One is the way scientists
talk about things.
We talk about our uncertainty.
When we go to give a
result to a colleague,
we never start by saying, I think this.
We start by saying, I
set out the experiment
and I considered these variables,
and I recognize this level of uncertainty
and, given all this, it
suggests that the answer is X.
When a scientist says,
the data suggests this,
that's actually an
extremely strong statement
from a scientist.
But that's not the way
it's heard by other people.
When we talk that way, we start by saying,
here's all the uncertainty.
Here's all the things that aren't known.
The non-scientist hears
this message and goes,
they don't know what
they're talking about.
They're hearing the uncertainty?
So that's a chunk in how it's done.
And, what I did with the city,
and that's the whole process
of doing the scenario
as opposed to probabilities
of earthquake occurrence,
I'm focusing on what we know,
which are the consequences
of the disaster,
rather than on what we don't know,
which is when it's going to occur.
So, as scientists, we're more interested
in what we don't know, 'cause
that's where the research is.
So, exactly what percentage
of climate change
comes from human activity?
That's an interesting scientific question.
But when you talk about it that way,
you aren't emphasizing that, in fact,
a big chunk, we know
comes from human activity.
We know.
But we don't say it that way
because, as scientists, we communicate.
The other issue is that we need to,
The sociologists tell us that
when you give a problem without a solution
you increase anxiety and
reduce the ability to act.
If you want people to take action,
you need to combine the pro,
you give the problem,
here's what you do about it.
And, that's what happened
with me in Los Angeles.
I said, here's the problem
and here's what we can do.
Fix these buildings, get this water.
On climate change, we need to say,
The scientists are uncomfortable saying
it's somebody else's
job how to deal with it.
We know we gotta reduce carbon,
but that's somebody else's job.
Whereas, I think if we say,
lookit, here's the problem,
and what we can do about it is
develop better renewable energy resources,
so that we don't have
to keep on doing this.
And, besides, we're
running out of oil anyway.
Eventually, we're gonna burn it all up.
We're gonna have to move there
and the only question is
how much social disruption
we go through before we get there.
Now you've got, oh,
there's something I can do.
I just make sure my elected officials
promote development of
renewable energy and, besides,
that means we'll be in the driver's seat
in the brave new world when
oil is no longer in control of things.
- What you're describing is the need for,
I'll call it, a mediating class of people
who know the science and
who have worked in the political process
and part of their task would be
to create the narratives
that make sense for the political leaders.
Is that fair?
- It's only part
of the problem because, there
are a certain number of these.
There are people who get
their science degrees,
go become congressional fellows,
are staffed to different
types of elected officials,
and have been in that
sort of interpretive role.
So we've sort of already
got that function.
What we don't have is the scientist
willing to reach out to meet them.
So it's more than saying,
we need someone to interpret it.
Often we're trying to
create scientific products
that better address the answers.
So, what I've done here,
we have our scientists
saying what the risks are.
We have people in the political sphere
that can accept science.
But we needed to make
this product that said,
here's what the implications
of these scientific hazards are.
We sometimes call it risk translation,
how to go from the hazards to the risk,
which is an interdisciplinary
scientific development process.
It's because it's so interdisciplinary,
it's very hard to get it moving,
or who has the mission for it?
The US Geological Survey
has supported me doing this,
but, fundamentally, our
mission is the hazards.
I push the comfort zone by
going in in this direction
and we're making a decision now.
Society needs it too much.
We have to keep on going.
But it's an uncomfortable process.
- You have talked about communication.
You've talked about
the failings of science
with regard to this dimension (mumbles).
What about leadership,
political leadership?
You've worked with the mayor.
That experience was very successful.
Can you identify some
of the characteristics
that you think political leaders
will have to have in the
future to manage this?
They're gonna have to
have a science education
it sounds like, but also, be sensitive to
the kinds of solutions
and the political costs
in navigating that terrain.
- I think that what we need is
intelligence to be able to
make all of these connections.
And, a commitment to a future vision.
To be able to move beyond
just the election cycle.
I'd say, in general, we're seeing
a certain amount of
this at the city level.
Mayor Garcetti loved to tout a book called
If Mayors Ruled the World,
which is just a recent analysis of,
sort of where the progressive, innovative
stuff is happening is
often in these, the mayors
especially in the larger cities.
Because once you get up to
higher levels of government,
I think there's sort of more
tensions pulling in different directions.
You get to the federal
level, we're a money,
feds tend to be a money source,
but it's very hard to do a solution
because it's just too big a problem.
And, especially, when you look at
issues around natural disasters.
The rate of earthquakes is not increasing,
but the number of people
living in earthquake areas is.
And the rate of meteorologic
disasters is going up.
This is going to be a
major issue in our future.
The emergency managers like to
say, all disasters are local.
In the end, it's what
happens in your community.
It's individuals and neighborhoods.
If all disasters are local,
all resilience is local too.
If we really wanna get this through,
it's about my pipes, my buildings,
and my neighborhood and my community,
and, will life be so
awful that my community
is no longer worth staying with?
So it's both dealing with the
very practical physical things
but also, making it a community
that people wanna stay in
that's worth fighting for
and is worth helping recover,
'cause it's not gonna be easy.
- Well, on that note, Dr.
Jones, I wanna thank you.
And, by the way, I wanna congratulate you
because, for all of your
work, you were just awarded
the Samuel J. Heyman
Service to America Medal
in Citizen Services last
week for your work in LA.
- It was really amazing.
As I said, I thought that I was
walking away from recognition
'cause I just saw it
as too important to do,
and it's been very satisfying,
as some of these accolades
have come through
and recognizing people want,
People want science.
We can make a difference and
we just have to figure out how to
bridge the gap in communication.
- Well, on that very positive note,
thank you very much for
being on our program.
And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(electronic, alerting music.)